today on the matt walsh show the left
celebrates the death of rush limbaugh
proving again
that they really do hate you and want
you dead also five headlines including
the disastrous winter weather across the
south
you know if you think that the deep
freeze in texas is evidence against
global warming think again the media
tells us that it's even more proof
of their climate change theories and in
our daily cancellation we'll discuss
the uh mysterious spike in adhd cases
that we've seen during the lockdowns
what could be the cause of that
it's a big mystery we'll talk about all
that and more today on the matt wall
show
you know i just cannot emphasize enough
the importance of using a vpn you don't
have to give big tech companies
access to your data why would you i
choose to protect my online activity by
using expressvpn ever wondered how
free to access social media companies
make their money well they do it by
tracking your searches your video
history everything you click on
and then selling your valuable data when
you use expressvpn you
make your online presence anonymous by
hiding your ip address
and that makes your activity more
difficult to trace more difficult to
sell to advertisers you get the privacy
that you deserve
what's more expressvpn encrypts 100 of
your data to protect you from
eavesdroppers on your network
and the expressvpn app couldn't be
easier to use as i always say you know
if it was not easy to use then i
couldn't do it so you know the fact that
i'm using
expressvpn means that you can do all you
got to do is just tap one button
on your phone computer and you're
protected and then um
and then you know that you can you can
go you can use the internet and you have
that anonymity um
and you have that privacy that you need
that that protection there's just
no good reason to use the internet
without a vpn
so take back your online privacy with
the vpn that i trust at
expressvpn.comwalsh
by visiting my link you'll get an extra
three months of expressvpn service for
free
on a one year package that again is an
extra three months of expressvpn service
for free on a one year package again
that's
expressvpn.comwalshexpressvpn.comwalsh
expressvpn.comwalls to protect your data
today
rush limbaugh died on wednesday at the
age of 70 though his lung cancer
diagnosis
has been publicly known for months of
course still his death has managed to
feel somehow
shocking that's that's how it always
feels when a man of great
consequence and importance reaches the
end of his
of his time here on earth and that's one
thing that nobody can deny about
rush limbaugh rush rush's life it was
important it was an important
consequential life
he was a pioneer a legend he changed the
country
in ways that few media figures ever have
ever could ever will anyone who doubts
russia's profound
importance need only take a glance at
social media
and there they'll find of course many
people paying grateful tribute to the
radio icon and talking about him
and all the ways that they were
personally motivated by him and
influenced by him and shaped by him but
um another and perhaps more profound
indication of russia's importance
is that all of the worst people in the
country many of the most
vile and disgusting ghouls that our
culture has produced
have come out to celebrate his death
openly and to dance on his grave without
shame
i'm not going to amplify any of these
people individually by going through a
list of all of the filthy disgusting
things they're spewing
suffice it to say that the phrase rotten
hell and rest in piss
were trending minutes after news broke i
mean minutes after news broke of
russia's death
right away these are not just random
anonymous internet trolls either
i mean there are a lot of those but also
some of the most prominent left-wing
voices who
when they're not laughing at a man for
dying of cancer who are busy lecturing
us about the need for
civil political discourse media outlets
showed similar lack of restraint rolling
stone's headline read quote
rush limbaugh right-wing radio host who
trafficked in bigotry and cruelty
dead at 70. the daily beast was only
slightly more subtle saying rush
limbaugh the human megaphone who
hijacked the gop
dead at 70. and of course the fever
fever swamps
of the left-wing blogosphere were not
subtle at all
jezebel's top headline was simply good
riddance in other words the media and
the left have showed the grace dignity
poise
compassion that you'd expect which is
none at all rush i think deserved better
than to have
the story of his death become a story
about the jerks who are rejoicing over
it but it is worth
thinking about this now familiar routine
we live in a country where this sort of
thing happens so automatically that we
aren't shocked by it anymore
when a famous person of a certain
political persuasion
certain ideological persuasion dies we
expect
that satan and hell will be trending on
twitter because of all the
users openly fantasizing about their
political enemy
roasting eternally in a place that by
the way they don't even think exists
and that's exactly what happened in in
in russia's case right on cue but
why does it happen it seems insufficient
to chalk it up to mere
partisanship mere divisiveness
what's really fueling it to answer that
question the first thing we have to
establish
is that this is truly a left-wing
phenomenon
i'm not claiming that nobody on the
right did any football spiking
or made any jokes about the death of
ruth bader ginsburg or some other
recently deceased liberal okay what i'm
claiming
is that those reactions were
representative of a definite minority
on the right there has not been a time
in my memory correct me if i'm wrong
when rest in piss or anything like it
was trending in reaction to the death of
a famous prominent left winger
and when has that ever happened for the
most part
rbg was eulogized respectfully both by
the left and the right
there are notable exceptions but those
exceptions are just that exceptions
on the left the respectful eulogy of
political opponents has become itself
the exception
it is an exceedingly rare exception
shameless celebration is the norm now
it's it's what you expect to see
and it's what you do see what drives
this i think is the same thing that
drives
cancel culture to a great extent it's
the belief again not totally unique to
the left but more prevalent by a wide
margin on the left
that people with differing views are bad
people
not just that they have bad opinions bad
ideas but they
that they themselves are bad deep down
in their souls
the consequence of casting every
political disagreement every alternate
opinion every opposing argument
as racism or sexism or homophobia or
transphobia or whatever other ismophobia
is that those
those who are conditioned into thinking
this way will come to believe that their
opponents are truly and
irredeemably evil so it's easy to make
jokes as i have many times about the
fact that the left calls
everything and everyone bigoted right
but the not so funny reality is that a
great many americans especially younger
americans
really believe this framing they really
believe it
they've taken it to heart it is the lens
through which they view
reality they they look out at the world
and they see
millions of wicked worthless racist
knuckle-dragging sub-humans staring back
at them that's the world they see
they don't recognize the humanity of
their opponents they certainly cannot
see any goodness or virtue in them
the reaction to rush limbaugh's death is
not happening in a vacuum it's not a
matter of
random anonymous trolls simply trying to
get a rise out of people
it's a reflection of our culture and of
the ideological divide and of
how deep that divide is and of the pure
unbridled
hatred that has helped to carve it
rush was the relentless target
um of this equally relentless hatred for
much of the past four decades
as i'm sure he expected that has not
changed after his death if anything it's
just ramped up
the man achieved many great things and
made his mark in many
countless and incalculable ways but one
of the deepest
testaments to his life is that these
sorts of people
are rejoicing over its end
may we all have hope to have that kind
of impact
on the world
let's get now to five headlines
we talk a lot about the companies we
don't like uh here's one of the
companies that we do like and that we
should support because they support us
and they're working for us
they've been doing a lot of work on the
ground in the culture that's 40 days for
life
i've been a big supporter of 40 days for
life
for a long time because of the work that
they do the state of our culture
frustrates all of us right we now have
politicians lobbying for infanticide
but you know where i see real progress
is the grassroots level and that's with
40 days for life
and i've and i've said this before that
if we're going to really fight the
culture war we got to do it on the local
local level on the ground floor
grassroots level that's what 40 days for
life does 40 days for life went from one
peaceful prayer vigil in front of a
planned parenthood in texas
to now a thousand cities in 66 countries
40 days of prayer fasting and law
abiding vigils have saved
18 000 babies from abortion it's helped
211 abortion workers leave their jobs
and close 107 abortion
facilities including the texas location
that now serves as the headquarters of
40 days for life
so they are actually saving lives
they're going out there and saving lives
thousands of lives you can be a part
of the beginning of the end of abortion
by joining one million volunteers and
sign up for your location at
40daysforlife.com
you can also stay updated on the number
one pro-life podcast 40 days for life
the largest spring campaign ever is
happening from february 17 through march
8th
so we are in the middle of it right now
just kicked off
you want to be a part of that campaign
be a part of this great organization
that i've supported for so long don't
wait for washington to heal our culture
go to work in your neighborhood at
40daysforlife.com
well if you think that the deep freeze
across the south is
evidence against global warming then
think again
suckers here's the headline from the
guardian and there's been many headlines
like this i'm just kind of picking one
here
it says heating arctic may be to blame
for snow storms in texas
scientists argue now the article says
associating climate change normally
connected with roasting heat with an
unusual winter storm that has crippled
swathes of texas
and brought freezing temperatures across
the southern us can seem
counterintuitive but scientists say
there's evidence that the rapid heating
of the arctic
can help push frigid air from the north
pole much further south
possibly to the u.s mexico border
this week a blast of winter weather has
reached deep into the heart of u.s
causing several deaths and knocking
out power for about five million sleet
and ice have battered oklahoma and
arkansas
while many people in texas have been
left marooned amid unsafe travel
conditions in homes with no electricity
judah cohen who's the director of
seasonal forecasting and atmospheric and
environmental research said the current
conditions in texas are historical
certainly generational but this can't be
hand waved away as if it's entirely
natural
well let me stop you right there i i
think we can sir i'm not i don't know if
that counts as hand waving or not but
yes it's natural this is the definition
of a natural thing this is a natural
event uh it's weather it's part of
nature
so yes we we can we can call it natural
that doesn't mean we
dismiss it as insignificant or whether
we don't care about the people that are
affected by it but
yes absolutely natural hurricanes are
natural tornadoes are natural drought is
natural
none of it is good but it is natural
um but he says this is happening not in
spite of climate change it's in part due
to climate change
last year cohen co-authored a paper that
found a strong uptick in winter storms
in the u.s northeast in the decade
leading up to 2018.
this cohen some other scientists argue
is a symptom of heating in the arctic
occurring at a rate more than twice the
global average
that is disrupting long-established
climatic uh
systems so you know this this is this is
the way it works
right that um well if you have the
theory of global warming
and then you notice that things are
happening and there you know the
winters are getting colder in some areas
and so on
you could say well maybe this is
evidence
against our theory or you could say no
no our theory is definitely right we got
to figure out a way to fit this into it
this this
we we're starting from the from the uh
supposition that our theory
is definitely must be right and so
anything that happens has to fit into it
and that's why i i think the the left is
very good at this we know they're very
good at rebranding they're very good at
coming with coming up with euphemisms
for things
um they're very good at changing the
narrative simply by changing the
language
they got a real talent for this and i
think their their mona lisa
their greatest achievement when it comes
to this
is climate change where they went from
it's it's now it seems pretty simple and
kind of obvious
but they went from global warming to
climate change
and they say well global warming is
still under that banner but it's climate
change that's the new thing
and the great thing about you know
climate change
if you're arguing for that is that
nothing can disprove it
in fact it's not just nothing disproves
it everything that happens
proves it everything that happens fits
into it
and it makes sense when you think about
it because climate
change yeah well the climate changes
climates have always done that
earth's climate has been in a constant
state of change ever since
the earth existed ever since the earth
had a climate it has been
a that's what climates do speaking of
nature
by their nature climates change
you know you're not going to have a
absolutely stable climate that is always
exactly the same
anywhere so um
you change it to climate change and yeah
you still get global warming but
if you've got freezing then you can add
that in
drought rain tornado hurricane
whatever put it all in earthquakes i
don't know if they throw that into now
maybe they will eventually get around
that
but it all it's all part it all proves
it
number two i want to play this for you i
missed it yesterday but biden did a town
hall on tuesday night i didn't watch i
don't care
uh the media fawned all over it as
always and i don't care much about that
either but this one segment on cnn did
stand out a little bit i want you to
listen to this
can you just weigh in finally jim on the
humility i mean when he talked at the
end of the town hall about
like i wake up in the white house and i
asked joe where are we and i'm
uncomfortable with them putting my suit
jacket on and having all this help i
mean
what a what a breath of fresh air
boy it's true bobby i teared up at that
that's scranton joe
that's the kid who watched his dad go to
work every day and struggle and
and then one day he got to grow up and
be the president of the united states of
america
and it really is an amazing moment i
remember the first days of the obama
administration the president coming down
to me and saying
we want the girls to do the dishes and
the white house staff seem to be a
little concerned about that
you know each president figures out how
to live in that place
but it was amazing to see scranton joe
kind of be honest about
saying wow this is my life yeah i'm
taking a page from the first lady
michelle obama when she said don't clean
the girls room they're cleaning their
own room
that's how it goes in my house too
exactly
yeah he teared up i'm sure he did for
his own sake
for his own sake i mean the benefit of
the doubt and assume
that he didn't really tear up and he's
just making it up for uh
because he thought it would sound good
on camera um which it never does
a man saying that he cried about
something never makes you sound better
but um uh well we have talked about
there i think
i think we've decided there are five
acceptable circumstances for a man to
cry
and the five acceptable circumstances
change depending on what i think they
must be because
you know of course i get to i'm the one
that gets to decide this um
but but crying at a politician's town
hall
definitely never on the list never on
the ever changing list
um so there's that
but also this this trying to frame
biden as this kind of um
you know regulars they said scranton joe
he lived in scranton for about 15
seconds
and uh and then he was in delaware and
but for the last 40 years he's been in
washington 40 or 50 years
he's been in washington so trying to
turn him into this regular guy
is this awe shucks guy who's now in the
white house and
you know he's not comfortable there he's
not comfortable with people people
tending to him and putting his jacket
he was a vice president i'm sure he had
people putting his jacket on for me was
vice president he lived in the white
house this is the most familiar thing in
the world to him
he's been in this environment running in
these circles
for decades
is this he's he is very far from a
regular guy
he has been in a position of
political power significant political
power for
for almost twice as long as i've been
alive
not quite that long i'm 35 but uh
a lot longer than i've been alive he's
been in positions of significant
political power including
pink being in the white house before for
eight years as vice president
i get that you probably don't get all
the same perks as uh as vice president
that you do as president
but i'm sure people tending to you and
putting coats on and stuff like that's
probably part of the bargain i imagine
as vice president
okay um this is from fox news we've
talked about the controversy the
quote unquote controversy um around the
bachelor
and uh the host of the bachelor
who's now stepped down from his position
and what did he do wrong because he was
advocating for forgiveness and grace
that's what he did wrong
he was advocating for the forgiveness
and grace towards another bachelor
contestant
who was photographed three years ago at
an old south themed
frat party which means apparently that
she's racist so
fox news has the the latest on this
rachel lindsay is speaking out after her
interview with bachelor host chris
harrison that led him to stepping away
from the franchise
lindsay who made history as the first
black bachelorette interviewed harrison
and asked about contestant rachel kirk
cannell's past racist behavior that
included attending an old south themed
party at a plantation
in 2018. harrison ended up defending
kurt canel in the interview which
prompted backlash and ultimately led to
his decision to step aside for a time
of personal reflection now uh yeah so
this this all stemmed from
this interview rachel lindsay was the
interviewer and she's a black woman um
and now somehow and i say somehow
like rhetorically but she has become
the victim of this or one of the primary
victims
of chris harrison's opinion that he
expressed
and here's what she says because she
said she was asked herself like
can you forgive chris harrison will you
ever be able to forgive him
forgive him for what forgiving
he who interviewed him and asked him
about something and he gave his opinion
about it
in the interview your interview you were
the host you brought it up
and he gave his opinion now he has to
apologize to you for answering your
question
well she says she really hasn't she
hasn't been able to forgive him yet
here's what she said quote it's a little
hard for me because i lived the
experience
there was no apology the apology came
after the fact
so it's hard for me to fully accept it
i'm going to need that time and space
and compassion that he referenced to
really accept the apology
because chris wasn't apologetic at first
i'm not saying i can't get there it's
just initially
it's a little tough for me oh is it a
little tough for you rachel it's a
little tough for you
it's a little tough for you that you're
giving an interview and you asked a guy
a question he answered it
is that tough for you did that make your
tummy hurt
sorry to hear that rachel first of all
the apology came after the fact yeah
that's how apologies work
they can't come before the fact if
someone's apologizing for something
before they do it
there's an apology i certainly wouldn't
accept
i can't accept the apology because it
came after the fact
when else would an apology come except
in this case there never should have
been an apology
because there was nothing to apologize
for literally all the guy did
was advocate grace and forgiveness that
was it that was his whole stance
but that not allowed to do that now
because grace and forgiveness that's off
the table
it's not if you're not simply wrong for
advocating grace and forgiveness you are
now racist yourself
and whoever you whoever you do this
advocacy in front of they are now a
victim of having to listen to you
so this is an interview host
victimized by the answers to the
questions that she
asked here's a headline from buzzfeed i
feel like i'm sort of victimized by this
emma stone looks completely
unrecognizable as a punk rock version of
cruella deville in the first movie
poster
so this is something you didn't know you
needed and you still don't need in fact
but emma stone is going to be there's
there's an origin story for corella
deville the villain from 101 dalmatians
so they're giving her an origin story
and a lot of people seem to be excited
about this
they came out with the the trailer
yesterday and let's take a look at that
here's the trailer
from the very beginning i realized i saw
the world differently than everyone else
that didn't sit well with some people
but i wasn't for everyone
i guess they were always scared that i'd
be
a psycho
but a new day brings new opportunities
and i was ready to make a statement
how does the saying go
i am woman hear me roar
i'm just getting started darling
the thing is i was born brilliant
born fast i'm a little bit mad
how completely absolutely
stupid is that i hope you really did
cancel your your disney it's all the
more reason to cancel your disney plus
if you didn't already do it i mean the
canceled disney plus thing was happening
last week because of them canceling gina
carano who now
as you've heard is uh part of the daily
wire team and she's been making a movie
for us
but um if if that wasn't enough reason
to cancel disney here's here's another
reason because this is this is what
they're putting out now
the origin story of corella deville
which which number one question why
is once again i have this this the same
the same question
but all these different remakes and
sequels and origin stories and prequels
and everything
there's why does why do we need more of
this story
there's not enough there corella deville
she it's a cartoon character her entire
role
right is to be a woman who for some
reason has a horrible grudge against
dogs actually i kind of can relate to
her on that level at least
so if anyone would be on board given my
feelings about dogs
if anybody would be interested if
there's any target audience for the
corella deville origin story it would be
me
and i'm not interested but her whole
role is to be some evil woman who for
some reason
hates dogs i mean there are plenty of
reasons but she she has a real murderous
passion
she and she hates dogs especially and
what she wanted what was the
the plot she wanted to make a coat out
of the dogs and then they had to escape
her
is it is there enough there for an hour
and a half
origin story who wants to see it
and i guess they're going to turn her
into like a cool
kind of like sexy sympathetic character
but she's a serial killer of animals
that's where this story is heading
are we going to see that in this movie
are we going to see when she first
starts murdering animals
is that where this is going because i
mean if they're going for like a
joker rated r really disturbing thing
then okay it's an odd choice but all
right i could see that
but if they're going for pg pg13 cool
fun for kids i don't see it
how's peter going to react to this they
are they are normalizing a woman who
abuses animals
i'm offended personally five
finally i may be stretching a little bit
by putting this in the headline section
but i i think it's a headline it's a
headline
in my heart anyway in my mind it's a
headline i participated along with the
other dw guys in a
version of the newlyweds game even
though none of us are newlyweds
so our wives were asked questions about
us and then we had to guess the answers
the answers that they gave about us you
can go to you can go to the
daily wire youtube and watch that video
if you want uh
i allegedly lost the game i think i came
in third allegedly
i wanted to play this for you this is
one section in particular that has
sparked controversy
global controversy everyone is talking
about this the question was
that was asked to our wives what
superpower would your husband want to
have
now i said that i said number one i
haven't thought about this question
because i'm not a child but if i had to
answer it
i would probably want aquaman's powers
that's what i said
my wife responded super strength is what
she thought my answer would be
now i said that counts because aquaman
has super strength
but ben ben shapiro disagreed and a
vicious intense debate ensued
let's listen to that now matt you
answered aquaman
your wife she said super strength
i think aquaman has super strength that
counts that because he's got super
strength doesn't he
i'm getting in my head that that does
not count well aquaman is not uh
as a dc guy no aquaman does not have
super strength he happens to be a strong
person but his power is to talk to fish
come on
his power is magnified underwater also
because things are less heavy
so when he's fighting the giant squid or
shark whatever he does that doesn't take
super strength
he's got he's got the the trident the
trident really helps him a lot in that
it's not like a physical
one-on-one like root i could pull up a
picture of aquaman
right now he looks like a strong guy to
me oh no he's a very strong guy dude
i mean jason mamoa is a monster but
that's just because he's a monster of a
human like in real life he's a monster
okay well who's who's the judge here
who's deciding
i'm going to decide and we're going to
give you 2.5 out of 5 points for that
because
i do think aquaman has super strength
there's no other way for him to be
fighting those
creatures that he's fighting this is
rigged so we're giving 2.5 points
for that one you can see there i
destroyed ben with facts and logic i
destroyed him and i got robbed in the
end this is a this is a scam i want an
audit on these results
this was completely rigged now i went
and looked this up okay
because how about do your research do
your research you want to talk about
aquaman and his powers
i did my research i went to
screenrant.com
with it with an article um and they're
the authorities on this i guess i've
decided
15 powers you didn't know aquaman had
well you might not have known but i did
and here they go through the powers of
aquaman this is screenrant.com15
night vision intense heat resistance
um telepathy i mean aquaman
this is why i wanted to be aquaman
everyone laughed at me when i said
aquaman well here you go
he can summon undead sea life
all right that's i don't know how often
that really comes in handy but if you
wanted to bring
like a dead octopus back to life you
could do that um
11 access to the clear i don't know what
that means and then
number 10 superhuman strength
they say aquaman may be the strongest
character in the sea but he's certainly
not the strongest on land in fact most
comic book readers consider him to be
the weakest among the justice league
members
but that could not be further from the
truth aquaman has demonstrated a unique
set of skills and superpowers when
combating enemies and has even shown the
ability to go toe-to-toe with the man of
steel
but how strong is he really the average
atlantean is able to lift up to two tons
significantly more than the average
human
more than the average human two tons i
don't know about you but i think that
makes
superhuman strength so i should have
been awarded
five points not two and a half i don't
know if that's enough
to lift me over the top to win the game
but um
when you account for pain and suffering
as well that i endured i think
ultimately i did win that game so i just
wanted to make that clear and that was
your final
big news headline let's go now to read
the comments uh cade burstra says hey
matt can you tell us something that you
actually enjoy
when most people would assume that you
hate that thing
uh i would say ballet a big i'm a big
ballet fan
i like to perform in ballet um and watch
ballet so that's
nobody expected that that's probably my
answer individual identity says rest in
peace
peace rush he had bravely faced death
it's sad to see him go
uh and yeah i mentioned that yesterday
about him i think of
you know another great testament to him
his final months uh on earth i think he
he faced his own mortalities on death
with a lot of dignity a lot of
a lot of courage um which
i that time has not come for me yet but
uh it could come any time so
come from anyone else uh i imagine i
imagine that that's not easy to do
and you know we we all spend i think
most of our lives trying to push those
thoughts of death and mortality out of
our minds we don't like to think about
it we
try to distract ourselves from it and
then uh and then you know you get that
call from the doctor you get that
diagnosis whatever it is
and now you're you're staring it right
in the face you can't avoid it anymore
it's right there
i think the reaction of a lot of people
probably is to still try to find a way
to deny it
and try to find sort of a way around it
distract themselves
um it seemed like rush was really
looking it in the eyes
and confronting it for what it was and
that
immense amount of respect and admiration
for that corey hilata says
who needs a daily wire membership when
the matt wall show is free yeah but stop
being a freeloader
and get the membership anyway uh chloe
says matt walsh can you please explain
in detail what your burrito tasted like
yeah we posted this uh if you haven't
watched this after this
show's over go to my video we posted a
video of me giving my own burrito recipe
my my dream of becoming a tv chef has
been fulfilled very excited about that
um what it tastes like i almost don't
want to give it away because if anyone
hasn't seen the video yet i want them to
see it the only thing i'll say is that
it was reminiscent of uh sort of like
cold vomit
and i mean that in the best possible way
and kalis finally says if i may ask what
the heck is on your wall
like is it supposed to be art or i don't
know what that is i've been i want to
make clear i've been broadcasting from a
hotel during
the the the winter disaster i've been at
a hotel because our studios are shut
down
and i can't really broadcast in the
house with four kids there so this is
where i've been in a hotel broadcasting
and so don't blame
you know the the little bit of
decorating and decor you see around
don't blame me for that or more
precisely don't don't blame my wife for
that it was this is not her doing
this is my hotel's doing so give them
credit or the blame whatever you want to
do
well we just celebrated uh valentine's
day who cares about that but then we
celebrated celebrated president's day
and
you know i'll tell you the reason why i
don't celebrate president's day
i'm protesting president's day and the
presidency in general
is that it has been there's a problem
i've talked about before
it's been over a century since we've had
a president with any kind of facial hair
and longer than that since we had a
bearded
president this is a real problem um and
that's why i was thinking about that and
it made me think even more about our
very good friends over at beard supply
believe it or not you know there are
other big celebrations happening this
this uh forget about president's day
because the beardless presence we don't
want them
how about febru harry okay happy happy
fabu harry everyone
it's this is the time of year to get
harry to uh
grow your beard out but please do
yourself and all of us a favor and do it
in style beard supply is running a promo
on all of their
beard oils right now you can buy one get
a second one 50 off no
no promo code necessary none of that
just head on over to beardsupply.com
to get discounted today i get asked all
the time
um how i how did i develop this glorious
manly magnificent um
beard and the answer is you know it's
just
my own inner essence okay is what is
what grows this beard for me
testosterone and all you need that too
but beard oil is a big part of it and i
use beard oil beard
from from from beard supply you should
do beard oil not only moisturizes away
the itch it also nourishes your hair for
a better looking beard overall
so grab one oil today get a second one
50 percent off
this discount is up at the end of the
month so better get over there very
quickly
visit beardsupply.com to buy one oil get
a second one 50
off that's beardsupply.com and i want to
give a quick
shout out to all of our daily wire
members you guys are the ones that keep
us in business i don't usually do shout
outs but uh i do one here
we love making content that matters and
while we're on the front lines of the
culture war
we can't do it without your support if
you're still skeptical about joining the
daily wire a reader's pass is a great
start a great value
kind of the gateway drug for the daily
wire
a reader's past will enable news junkies
to read our articles ad-free including
op-eds from ben shapiro which are
exclusive to daily wire members only you
get that
upgraded experience and in-depth
analysis from our editor-in-chief
you also get access to our mobile app
which has really become
popular with all of our members you can
get you can read all of our stories on
mobile
all of this the membership tier is
already a bargain at three dollars a
month but right now we're offering one
month
for 99 cents that's mobile ad free
access to all of the daily wire news
exclusive op-eds from ben shapiro and
breaking news and updates on our mobile
app
um all for the low price of a dollar one
dollar so
give it a shot it's worth it and let's
get now to our daily cancellation
more than once over the past several
months i have predicted that we would
see a reported skyrocket
we would see a skyrocketing rise of uh
adhd diagnoses as millions of children
are forced to sit and stare at screens
all day in lieu of receiving a real
education that's what i predicted
i think i said on the show multiple
times i tweeted it
now usually i enjoy saying i told you so
i don't hate saying i told you so i love
saying it
this is not one of the times where i
enjoy saying it uh this is one of the
times where i really do hate saying it
but
but i told you so this week um
nbc news reported right on schedule that
adhd diagnoses have
skyrocketed during the pandemic the
article by olivia solin
offers more details starting with an
anecdote this is what she this is what
she reports
it says susan mclaughlin's 12-year-old
daughter isabella was a straight-a
student before the pandemic isabella who
lives in a suburb of the suburb of
a suburb of columbus ohio excelled at
science and math and was already getting
high school credit for algebra
but when her school shut down in march
and classes shifted to zoom isabella
great
isabella's grades took a nosedive she
signed on for her virtual class from a
desk piled high with books papers and
stuffed animals and then spent hours
trying to clean her room
instead of focusing on schoolwork she
found herself paralyzed by assignments
mclaughlin said
but she wouldn't tell her teacher over
email that she was struggling as she
would have done in person
mclaughlin 53 a mother of three from
delaware ohio says it was a meltdown
after meltdown after meltdown
mclaughlin spent months trying to bring
more structure to isabella's day by
writing lists schedules timelines
checkboxes
but as someone as someone who was
diagnosed with attention deficit
hyperactivity disorder herself a decade
ago
mclaughlin realized that she was seeing
the same behaviors in isabella
she thought quote i've got to nip this
in the bud
isabel is being evaluated by a
psychiatrist
a process that takes several hours and
requires her teachers to fill out
questionnaires about her behavior
mclaughlin hopes that with an adhd
diagnosis isabella will be able to get a
prescription for a stimulant medication
such as ritalin adderall
uh or something like that to alleviate
her symptoms okay
pausing her for a second strange
strange isn't it the child was a
straight a student
everything was fine then she was
confined to a house for a year
put in front of a screen and suddenly
she has trouble learning
she must have a mental disorder yes that
must be it no other explanation comes to
mind
more from nbc news it says two dozen
parents pediatricians psychiatrists
psychologists and researchers all
described a crisis among children
suffering from inattention
and tanking school performance
data from specialists involved with
diagnosis diagnosing and treating adhd
show
just how much parents are struggling to
get help they're flooding an adhd
support line with questions and adhd
diagnoses and prescriptions for related
medications have soared
the number of parents calling a helpline
set up for um set up by
children and adults with attention
deficit hyperactivity disorder that's an
organization a non-profit
that supports people with adhd rose by
62
since the pandemic started traffic to
its website last year grew by 77
compared to 2019. aetna health a
technology company that creates
uh creates practice management software
for healthcare providers
published research in may drawing on
data from its customers that showed an
increase in patients aged 13 to 17 who
received new diagnosis
diagnoses of adhd from the week of march
9th to the week of march 30th
the proportion of visits by teenagers
that involve first-time adhd diagnoses
rose by 67 percent that was a similar
spike among teenagers
especially boys okay
it should be i hope clear to most people
that it's not a coincidence to find so
many children having trouble with
inattention and hyperactivity when
they're cooped up
deprived of their normal outlets like
sports and other physical activities
and forced to learn through zoom classes
you know
i suffer quite a bit from inattention
when i
am forced to sit through even a
15-minute zoom meeting
i can't imagine doing it every day for
hours and being 12 years old on top of
it
the trouble here is with is with the
final d in adhd that's where i've got an
issue
or really both d's deficit and disorder
okay it's not only wrong
but arrogant and cruel to call a child
disordered
because he's struggling to learn in an
environment like that
the deficit the disorder is with the
environment
not the child it is disordered
to lock kids inside to try to teach them
through a screen
that's disordered kids who struggle
with that are healthy it's natural it's
healthy
to struggle under those circumstances
your kids should struggle actually
yes it may help it may help them sit
still to put them on drugs and
tranquilize them but if you're gonna do
that
and i don't think you should but if you
do it
don't pretend you're treating an illness
or a disorder don't don't don't
fool yourself you know you need your kid
to sit still and look at zoom for six
hours
and so you put them on drugs all right i
really wish you wouldn't i think it's
terrible to do it but
if you do at least be honest and do not
claim that you're treating a disorder
because you know you're not you know
that's not what you're doing
you're trying to get your kid a
competitive advantage in this certain
environment or context
okay like a guy who isn't good at
baseball
is not disordered um
not thriving in baseball is not a sign
of a disorder so if he takes steroids
he's not treating an illness he can't
say that he suffers from
a baseball deficiency no he's just
he wants to succeed in this specific
specialized environment known as
baseball
and so he's taking the drug to help him
do that
it's the same thing here a child who
doesn't thrive while staring at a screen
for five hours
is also not disordered that is not a
symptom of a disease
you know so putting them on drugs it's
like doping it's it's it's just to give
them that advantage
who is to say that children should
thrive in that environment
we've decided that we want them to
but that doesn't mean they should giving
him a drug to help is not a medical
decision then even if a doctor
prescribes it
you're also not doing it to help him
exactly the kids are being drugged while
they're stuck at home
in order to make things easier on the
teachers and on the parents and on this
system
generally that's who this is for
now i think this is probably clear to
most people as it relates to the spike
in adhd
during the pandemic i think most people
can put two and two together here right
here's the part where i might lose you
if you've been with me
so far maybe you turn on me here i don't
know
this same logic applies outside of the
pandemic
adhd diagnoses have been increasing for
decades we're seeing
what we're seeing during the lockdowns
is just a dramatic microcosm of our
general societal
situation before the pandemic and
presumably once this is over whenever
that is
we're gonna go back um to to you know
where kids are expected to sit in a
classroom with 30 other kids for six or
seven hours a day listening to lectures
filling out worksheets
taking tests based mostly on
memorization
now i think that's better than them
staring at a screen for six hours
but it's still not good at least not for
a lot of kids
kids who don't thrive in that specific
environment kids who struggle to learn
in that environment kids who struggle to
pay attention
are diagnosed as distorted disordered
and put on drugs
but just as a child's failure to thrive
on zoom
shouldn't be considered a symptom of
illness
a child's failure to thrive in public
schools should also
not be considered a symptom of illness
see
the adhd diagnosis is situational
it is diagnosed largely based on how the
child's disorder
quote unquote interferes with school and
home life
other illnesses aren't diagnosed this
way if you take your child to the doctor
because you think he has diabetes
the doctor is not going to ask you um is
his diabetes interfering with school and
home life
no that might be a non-sequitur who
cares what it's interfering with he's
got diabetes
let's get him treated but adhd is only
adhd if it causes
problems in these environments that's
those are the symptoms that's how they
determine it
the the mayo the mayo clinics fact sheet
on adhd says this this is what they say
okay reading now from the mayo clinic is
what they say about 80
about adhd they say a child who shows a
pattern of inattention may often
fail to pay to pay close attention to
details or make careless mistakes in
school work
have trouble staying focused in tasks or
play appear not to listen even when
spoken to directly
have difficulty following thrown
instructions and fail to finish school
work or chores
have trouble organizing tasks and
activities avoid or dislike
tasks that require focused mental effort
such as homework
lose items based uh lose items needed
for tasks or activities for example toys
school assignments pencils be easily
distracted
and finally forget to do some daily
activities such as forgetting to do
chores
okay yeah that that's how you know that
there's
adhd not only does this all sound
exactly like
every child i've ever met
but it also revolves suspiciously around
school work
what i'm arguing is that our underlying
assumption here is wrong
we're assuming so this is really a
philosophical thing
okay um the
the adhd discussion is a philosophical
discussion more than anything else
so you could i know i'm going to get the
emails and everything saying oh you're
not a doctor how could you be saying
this
what i'm saying is that the doctors who
are diagnosing this stuff
they are going outside of what their
realm should be
they're going way above and beyond
they're going way above their own pay
grade
and i'll tell you why
because to diagnose adhd
it is to assume that every child
should be able to sit still and pay
attention in a public school environment
i'm suggesting that some children many
children can't
and that's not because there's something
wrong with them
it's because there's something wrong
with us and with the system
and with the mold that we are trying to
put them in
so i believe that children who exhibit
adhd behaviors exist
obviously sure my sons do and they exist
i do and i exist last i checked what i
don't believe is that those behaviors
are disordered
see that that's again my issue is with
the d here
disordered in order to call something
disordered you must first have an idea
of what the proper order
is so what's the proper order for a
child
how is a child supposed to be how is he
supposed to act
how is he supposed to think
you say an adhd child thinks the wrong
way well what's the right way
who decided that
an adhd child has a lot of trouble
focusing on schoolwork
who's okay say he's supposed to be able
to do that
who's to say that he should be able to
do that
what do we who should someone maybe if
he could show me
what is the model brain that we're
basing all this on
if you're saying that a child has a
deficiency of attention
well how much attention is he supposed
to have
show me the child who all the other kids
are supposed to be like
what are we judging this against
and who decided that so don't tell me
whether
the doctors decided who who gave them
that authority
yeah a doctor can look and and
physically diagnose things but who gives
them the authority to decide
how a child is supposed to think and how
he's supposed to learn
and why have we seeded that that those
kinds of judgments over to
medicine that's philosophical is what
that is
it's a lot of other things too but it's
also philosophical
i suggest again that the real disorder
is with the system
i would argue that if there's an
education system
that cannot function unless millions of
the kids in its care
are drugged then the education system
is fatally flawed that to me
is a symptom of the education system
being disordered
so i'm going to be the doctor now
looking at the education system and
diagnosing it
and when i look and see that you
you can't function this doesn't work
unless millions of kids are on
psychotropic medication
yeah that tells me there's something
wrong here there's something very wrong
and it's not with our kids
it's with the system
and what they're doing now
during the lockdown is just evidence of
that
they're locking these kids down making
them go to school on a computer
and if it doesn't work they put him on
drugs it is
infuriating and disgusting
and we should all be uh
furious about it so
who's canceled um everybody everybody
involved
that's that's it's this is a very
general one adhd
maybe that's what's canceled here and
we'll leave it there for today thanks
for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadosky the
show is edited by danny d'amico
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by nika geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matte wall show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 21.
the great rush limbaugh goes to his
eternal reward
the new york times is very very worried
about unfettered conversations
and bill gates tries to take away our
beef check it out on the michael knowles
show